as technology continues to evolve cloud
computing has become an integral part of
businesses worldwide Amazon web services
AWS is a leading Cloud platform offering
a wide range of services and solutions
becoming an AWS expert in 2024 can open
up numerous career opportunities and
help you stay ahead in the everchanging
tech industry so in this video we will
outline a step-by-step guide to become
an AWS expert in the coming year so
first of all let's just start by
understanding what is AWS so AWS short
for Amazon web services is a cloud
computing platform provided by Amazon
think of it as a virtual space where you
can store your data run applications and
access a wide range of services without
needing a physical servers or
infrastructure it's like having a
powerful computer in the cloud that you
can use whenever you need it AWS offers
a vast area of services including
storage databases computing power
machine learning and more these services
are designed to be flexible scalable and
secure allowing businesses and
individuals to easily build and deploy
their applications and services with AWS
you can store and retrieve your data run
websites and applications process large
amounts of data and even create virtual
servers in just few clicks it provides a
reliable and cost effective solution for
businesses of all sizes from startups to
large Enterprises all right so this was
about AWS now let's understand the
responsibilities of AWS professional so
an AWS professional is responsible for
Designing implementing and managing
cloud-based Solutions using Amazon web
services they are experts in various AWS
services and possesses a deep
understanding of cloud architecture and
best practices their responsibilities
include accessing businesses
requirements designing SK scalable and
secure Cloud Solutions provisioning and
managing AWS resources optimizing
performance and cost ensuring high
avability and disaster recovery and
implementing security measures they also
provide guidance and support to the
teams troubleshoot issues and stay
updated with the latest AWS services and
Industry Trends so these were the
responsibilities of AWS professionals
now the average salary for AWS Cloud
engineer is
$115,000 per year in the United States
the average additional cash compensation
for AWS Cloud engineer in the United
States is
$8,000 which is pretty high package when
we add up these both overall an AWS
professional plays a crucial role in
leveraging AWS Technologies to drive
Innovation efficiency and business
growth so this was about the
responsibilities and salary now let's
have a look at its road map so the road
map to AWS so first of all understand
the AWS certification path so AWS offers
a comprehensive certification program
that validates your expertise in various
AWS services and solutions start by
understanding the different
certification levels such as
foundational associate professional and
Specialty each level focuses on specific
domains such as architecture development
operations and security reach the
certification requirements and choose
the path that aligns with their career
goals next you can do is gain hands-on
experience Theory alone is not enough to
become an awx expert hands-on experience
is crucial for understanding the
Practical aspects of awf services such
as Amazon light sale Amazon Lambda and
Amazon S3 browser start by creating a
free AWS account and explore these
services to gain practical experience
practice deploying applications on light
sale creating serverless functions with
Lambda and managing storage with S3
browser additionally consider working on
real world projects or contributing to
open source projects that utilize these
services this Hands-On approach will
deepen your understanding and
Proficiency in AWS making you a
well-rounded and knowledgeable AWS
expert after gaining the hands-on
experience you can move forward and
study AWS documentation so AWS provides
extensive documentation and white papers
that covers various services and best
practices dive into these services to
gain a thorough understanding of AWS
Services architecture patrons and
security practices stay updated with the
latest AWS announcements and releases to
stay ahead of the curve the next step is
enroll in AWS training courses AWS
offers a range of training courses both
online and in person to help you build
your expertise these courses cover a
wide range of topics from foundational
knowledge to advanced concepts consider
enrolling in AWS training programs such
as AWS certified Solutions architect AWS
certified developer or AWS certified
scops administrator depending on your
choosen certification path other than
these there is one another amazing
program known as AWS Cloud architect
master program by simply learn this AWS
Cloud architect certification course
will make you an expert in AWS that is
Amazon web services in this program you
will become familiar with architectural
patterns and services of AWS learn how
to design and deploy highly scalable and
for torrent applications on AWS
Implement AWS security and testing and
become an expert in AWS components such
as S3 and cloud formation in this you
will get a job assist program simply
learn job assist program is an India
specific offering in partnership with
imj jobs.com to help you land your dream
job to participate in job assist program
you need to be graduate in engineering
or equalent and complete your master's
program successfully and earn a master
certificate upon completion the next
step on the path is join AWS user groups
and communities networking and
collaborations are essential for
professional growth join AWS user groups
and communities to connect with
like-minded professionals and experts
participate in discussions attend
meetups and share your knowledge and
experiences engaging with AWS Community
will not only expand your network but
also provide valuable insights and
learning opportunities next thing you
can do is participate with mock exam
to prepare for AWS certification exams
practice with sample questions and take
mock exams this will help you
familiarize yourself with exam format
identify knowledge gaps and improve your
time management skills several online
platforms offer practice exams and study
materials specially designed for AWS
certifications so becoming an AWS expert
in 2024 requires dedication continuous
learning and hands-on experience by
following this comprehensive guide you
can build a strong found foundation in
AWS Services earn relevant certification
and stay ahead in the competitive tech
industry embrace the opportunities
offered by AWS and position yourself as
a sought-after professional in the cloud
computing domain all right guys with
that we have come to the end of this
video If you like this video please give
it a thumbs up I hope it really help you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here